something that's kind of strange that I
actually noticed because I've been
watching a lot of like time periods of
movies
the Purity that we talk about in virgins
the tradition that come from like
centuries realistically there's like a
pervy old man that were kind of like
trying to buy children from like other
families I'm not gonna lie listen my
grandmother my granddad like 14. that's
rubbish my grandmother my granddad they
got married and my grand my my
grandmother died at 100 years old my
granddad weren't pervy and they were
both virgins I'm not talking about your
granddaughter I'm trying to say that you
can't say a whole generation that
because it was traditional then there
was old men and pervy that they were
perving on young people well okay I was
put in another way don't generalize
don't generalize I'll just put into
another way I'm not you're picking like
a nice you know a nice example that is
beautiful well it's not sticking the bad
ones I'm giving it up that's great
that's fantastic another example like
child marriage it happens all over the
world it's just because and these are
the more traditional places in the world
in the Western World marriages in the
western I'm just explaining I'm just
explaining yeah that the more
traditional places in the world this
happens so if we're in the Western World
we're trying to go back into
motivational value where does it happen
Africa age
you don't know about child marriage no
my life you can't take extreme examples
no no no no because even Nigeria even
Africa is westernized I see people that
in Africa that speak that speak like
Nathan and they've never been to America
you understand yeah so you can't say in
Africa okay you can't take extreme
examples to explain what you're trying
to say child marriage
no no I'm saying that they speak like
American honestly no no no no no no no
no no I'm saying that there's people in
the that speak like they're American and
they've never been anywhere she's saying
Africa Africa is not what don't hate
Africa
I'm African too I'm angolan I know what
I'm talking about what I'm mentioning is
I mentioned Africa mentioned Asia I
mentioned certain parts in the world are
more tradition
I'm talking about what I know
even like literally it's one of the most
this is quite normal I don't know how
people don't understand this like how
underage girls yeah that shouldn't even
be having sex we're growing men they're
doing it because their families are
arranging this with it with other
families because of financial gaining
whatever and this has been the tradition
from back in the day kings and queens
days and that's what the idea of Purity
being what is favorite that's where it
comes from realistically if we really
stop to think about it and some of the
most traditional like the ones that have
not been tainted by Western by Western
um by Western ideals the majority of
marriages in Angola are not child
marriage oh by the way don't listen to
the stats this is a communist country
that actually said now wow
actually come and do that because it's
not fair like don't like it
it doesn't happen in Angola it like
child marriage does happen okay it does
happen it's something that is it's a
problem even even genital
um yes yeah mutilation those are things
but now you see we're in a society where
we recognize this as it is not meant to
be like this right so this is why these
issues are addressed but what we're
talking about is about modern uh modern
even in Nigeria there's no more even I'm
Igbo do you know how to say I'm a
traditional traditional that tradition
is still not there no it's traditional
list like you said but it's not a
traditional what's the difference
between culture
the legal age for marriage for both men
and women in Angola is 18 years old you
are right it's more prevalent it's more
it's more prevalent than it is here but
you you you speak as if it's
it's a oppressing like right why are you
speaking on something you don't know
I'll tell I'll tell you because I do
know one and then I'll tell you I'll use
another example I'm just all I'm trying
to do is expose the processes
I don't know because it's interesting
because what I like to do yeah is I like
people to explore their different ideas
for example you're telling go back to
the most traditional thing at EG Boko
Haram yeah this is just an example it's
extreme but just to explain what
traditionalism no but wait Boko Haram
what they stand for is basically against
Western culture because Western culture
in their eyes tainted the tradition what
is meant to be there what should be
there what do they do they take girls
and they marry them all over the world
all over all over like the place they
kidnapped them in fact and they're my
children and all I'm saying is that
actually the traditional idea the
traditional view of Purity is not
stemming from a woman why does a woman
have to be visual why does she have
definitions is that traditional okay
depending on the culture no because okay
no no no no no no because that is not
traditional throughout the whole West
the world that what you're talking about
is tradition that we is for that culture
the Western we call it the nice one
that's why that's culture for that
culture is not all over the Western
World and things are changing so that is
it every location if you look at how
many child marriages happen over the
whole Western World and look at the
percentages it's gonna be minute so you
can't stand here and make it like it's a
majority because it's not so traditional
traditional doesn't mean child marriages
by pervial men is what you're saying
that's not what I'm saying that is what
you said what I'm saying is for you to
understand I'm using you I don't want to
understand nothing you're saying I don't
want to understand you said that
tradition means that pervy old men are
gonna go and sleep with on the age do
you
know
the way YouTube example and then put it
into the context that's why I said that
you can't use that example to explain
what we're talking about and the one
thing you're taking I'm just the
question is
the one thing the one thing you're
taking out of context from a historical
perspective is people did not live as
long it was not because the men were
pervs it was because people had to get
started a lot quicker in order to
reproduce it was a reproductive strategy
the reason that men like pure women is
because they had to ensure paternity if
you were sleeping around screwing the
whole town they didn't know if that kid
was theirs it's not it's not that
they're pervy that makes sense okay it
was what is the difference between a 17
and an 18 year old okay then I'll ask
another question can I ask you a
question then yeah another example cool
if that is the case if that is the case
then again I'll just say kings and
queens all these times they married
young girls and they were not the same
age yeah young virginal women are have
yes okay
expectancy back then was even 35 I asked
the Eastern Romans it wasn't even 35 and
the girls married younger yeah people
got married younger because they did not
live as long yeah okay that was normal
back then right that was normal back
then and while I'm trying to explain
this idea this idea of Purity and youth
is coming from an outdated context I
think that's a cope because you don't
have it anymore
women that sleep around that are not
virgins they will say that and again
they have lots of sex that will turn
around because they want to find men
they need a man that's what they're
going to turn around and say Purity
don't matter because it can't matter
where you've lost it because that's one
thing you can't get back but you're
giving away your virginity so that's why
you have to say that you have to say it
don't matter so that you can get a man
you know you can get operations now
was like I really don't I really don't
buy this idea I think this is like one
of these weird things that where like
traditionalists pretend that like the
past was some great place and everyone
was super happy all the time everyone
made these decisions monogamy was the
perfect for everyone everyone was really
happy in their marriage and I think it's
a bit more nuanced than that I've seen a
lot of examples
um enough for me to question that
narrative that like maybe maybe the
first or second guy you got with the
married wasn't the best fit maybe you
know do you know something right in the
back in those days you made your bed you
lie in it yeah yeah you made your
bedroom line it and once you line it you
make it work as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible